the other day one of our guys that works
for us one of our executives his
daughter
uh uh oldest daughter goes to school
and she comes after school finishing
college four years and she can't stand
that that's that's philosophies
he says we had dinner and i'm like why
is my daughter whom i raised
so against me
why does she hate me so much because you
sent it to me hate these the
philosophies i have so much and and he
sat there and he's like man i don't know
and as a parent this is a fear because
you don't want to lose your kids you
love these guys this is an emotional
thing parents today fear am i one day
going to lose my kids my kids go to
school you guys know where they go to
and the best school in florida is right
across the street everybody knows what
the best school in florida is but that
best school in florida is not one that's
teaching conservative philosophy so my
mind i'm like at what age
do i consider allowing the kids because
it's under my control till 18 at what
age do you want to be comfortable to
send them there that anything can be
taught
it's not they're not praying they ain't
sitting there talking about god they
ain't sitting there talking about
certain values and principles go at it
right they can teach anything they want
to teach your kids well communism is an
option socialism is an option you can
marry whoever you want to be if that
person's a he she whatever all this
stuff is confusing to a young kid that's
going through it right but here's here's
what i'm convinced here's what i'm
convinced years ago i'm sitting with um
a guy that's uh uh
raised great kids dudley
big fan a big big mentor in my life
ran the biggest church in la and we're
sitting down
uh and i said listen give me tips on
parenting
and uh you know he was going through
something with his son at the time he
said there's three phases parents go
through first your kids idolize you
then they demonize you
then they humanize you it's a face
and a phase when parents go through
demonizing it sucks it absolutely
sucks because you're like am i ever
gonna get these guys
because you did something wrong as a
parent just a matter of time before you
screw up it doesn't matter you're going
to screw up as a parent right he says
then eventually he's humanizing okay so
take that philosophy and bring it to
capitalism okay
you're a kid who do you admire the
lifestyle of the rich and famous you're
like oh man one day did i love to have
that life how cool would it be if one
day mom i'm gonna buy you a house mom
i'm telling you i'm gonna buy you a
house dad i'm gonna buy you that ferrari
you want how many kids i've spoken like
that right
and then you go to school and the
teacher says rich people are bad all
they do is they treat their employees
like slaves and this is what they do for
their own and they sit home and they got
these big bellies and they make their
money and their their employees are
doing the work and they're golfing and
the kids are like
these are horrible people oh my gosh i
hate rich people mom
they're terrible
and then they come out of college hating
capitalists and rich people
and then they go to school and then they
go get a job and all of a sudden
somebody gets a promotion over them who
for whatever reason
was a better ass kisser
was closer was a better friend or
whatever but you're doing harder work
and that person gets the promotion over
you
and then you're 28 years old and now
you're making 78 000
and you have to pay 13 000 in taxes and
you're sitting there saying this
doesn't make sense
what the hell is this all about and
eventually you say
maybe these capitals are not that bad so
what i'm trying to tell you is
i think we're about to go through the
humanizing phase of people that are
creating jobs i think you're about to go
through the humanizing phase to sit
there and realize these principles kind
of make sense and eventually that 12
percent that runs america is going to
figure it out and say you know what i'm
kind of going to go to freedom not going
towards control i think that's what's
going to be taking place well i got a
theory on it i mean you know i've
thought about this a lot right so
think about there's two aspects of it
who who becomes a teacher who becomes a
writer becomes a professor pretty pretty
intelligent people but they don't make a
lot of money so they become very
resentful into the system because here i
am i went to school i went to school
after school and then i went to school
after school and i've got all these
degrees and i have all this education
but i'm making 60 grand a year meanwhile
the plumber you know who while i was
studying was was partying on friday
nights is making 200 grand a year and he
didn't go to college you know what i
mean this guy the truck driver is making
150 grand a year so they're resentful of
the system in that because they think
they should get paid for who they are
not for what they offer and that's a big
thing that that that people mess up you
don't get paid for what you like to do
unless you're literally the best in the
world at it adam you're very good at
basketball but you're not getting paid
for it because you're not one of
literally the best 300 in the world at
it right
so you have to be able to offer services
you can pave the driveway of one of
those guys that makes you know that kind
of money playing basketball and do a
real good life for yourself because that
guy doesn't want to pay his own driveway
you have to be able to offer value if
you're not the best in the world it's
something you have to be able to offer
value to the best in the world that's
number one number two
we go to school and we learn all about
the victories of government
think about it we learn about how
governments save the world in this war
we learned about how government saved
well history is written by the winners
exactly right so government's great with
the civil rights act government is great
let's not let's not talk about how
government implemented slavery let's
talk about how government stops slavery
like you get all the winds of government
so here we are they're preaching this
the egalitarian system where you know
your merit based on your education is is
what you should get paid on not not the
work that you do or your willingness to
do work
just how educated you are how smart you
are and look at how great government is
so these kids come out saying
government's great why wouldn't you want
to pay taxes this is how we do things
and then you grow up into the real world
and this is the whole thing with my
libertarian philosophy this is almost
every libertarian that i know it's like
dude
just show your work you want more taxes
we nobody nobody wants to drive on
decrepit roads and bad bridges
show what you do with the money because
right now you took three trillion and
gave us twelve hundred
and nothing changed everything got worse
there's empty shelves there's a i just
want to buy furniture at city at city
furniture nothing is there until the end
of march this is the united states of
america i got nothing to the end of
march you've got uh you know empty
shelves somehow there's valentine's day
candy but there's nothing else i have no
idea how that works
so we gave you guys three trillion
and where's that money and you want more
of it see that's the thing that the the
left never answers for
you always want more if three trillion
couldn't fix it then six trill your boy
robert reich more more more can you just
show your work with what you're doing
now
can you just at least once prove that
the money we gave you was worth
something yeah before you ask for more i
mean it's insane i think i think you can
only do that for so long i i don't think
you can that's that philosophy
sustainable so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]